[Musique]
samedi la ville de moore pas convié ses
habitants à commémorer l'armistice
la cérémonie s'est déroulée en deux
temps avec d'abord un premier passage au
cimetière pour fleurir les tombes
le cortège s'est ensuite rendu au
monument aux morts le maire a fait un
discours après avoir laissé son pupitre
aux élèves de cm2 de l'école élémentaire
mal me donne nous soit nous avons
travaillé sur les lettres de soldats
poilus suite à une intervention d'une
association d'anciens combattants qui
est venu par leur parler de la première
guerre mondiale
ils ont bon répondu donc aux questions
des enfants
l'école s'est impliqué dans le cadre du
devoir de mémoire et les enfants se sont
largement investis dans cette cérémonie
tous les ans les enfants participent ils
sont très impliqués on le voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui puisque beaucoup
d'entre eux ont appris par coeur dont
qu'ils ont mis du coeur
les amis du temps et de l'énergie ce qui
prouve que finalement ils sont très
attentifs aussi à ce devoir de mémoire
et j'en suis ravi plus qu'une lecture de
lettres
les écoliers ont largement pris part à
la commémoration chacun a déposé une
rose blanche au pied du monument et a
interprété plusieurs chants une
cérémonie qu'ils garderont en mémoire